hey everyone welcome back to how to
Hollywood I'm your host Kristen Gill and
today I have celebrity makeup artist
Jill Powell here with me once again she
did dummies makeup for the AMAs and it
was insane everyone has been talking
about it yes and everyone keeps asking
me what a lip is so I'm about to tell
you let's get started
okay so I prepped her skin with some
glow products some skin care hydration
eye cream and then I always use a primer
I use the NARS sheer glow foundation I
contoured a little bit with my favorite
NYX palette I always use it I love it
her cheeks are warm glow by Mac it's
like a mineralized blush and then I used
the new highlight by Mac I'm it's so
pretty
so I like to start out by like prepping
the crease I always say so this is just
like a future warm color and just kind
of carve out the crease so that
everything else can just lay on top of
that it's kind of your background work
isn't it yeah
all of these are matte and so this one
is called peach tea but it's like a
perfect just you know a little bit cheap
in the skin tone a little bit warmer
I wanted the look to have some fall
inspiration so you know when you think
of fall colors you think of the birdies
and the oranges and the Koppers that's
what we were going for yeah her lashes
too I was like oh my god everything
about this look is my memory I was so
excited you were coming in today like
yes gel is gonna come show us this
amazing pretty nice place okay so the
fans asked what made you decide that you
wanted to become a makeup artist love
you legend oh I actually always did my
own makeup like I played sports but I
would have a full face my mom always
said do what you love and you'll never
work a day in your life so you know at
the end of the day when I graduated
college I was doing makeup and I was
like I don't want to do sports medicine
I'll do makeup so well here
so I layered a few colors on the lid
it's cuz we were kind of deciding as I
was going so I did some Gold's and some
coppers do you ever look at it
throughout or you like don't look at it
until I'm done I always give her a
mirror so she can look if she wants to
and it depends sometimes she doesn't
look at her till again like oh love it
and then sometimes it's like every step
she's checking it out she also likes to
learn so sometimes she's like what you
do oh I like that color what was it so
once I did kind of the coppery colors I
wanted to
create some smokiness so I brought in a
black on the outer corners and I just
blended it so that it was a little bit
on her lid not too far up it really gave
some definition it's like just in that
kind of vicinity where it's like 3/4 of
the lid and then just right up into that
crease and then on top of that I blended
like a warm brown just because I didn't
want it to be super black but I needed
that intensity behind it so this is the
Sephora palette this one is a support
palette yeah I know you did that lilac
eye with the Sephora palette and I was
like I'm buying it yeah feels first
Derek to wants to know do you ever get
nervous while beating Demi's mug because
perfection can easily be ruined but you
managed to make her look even better
iconic the only time I ever get nervous
is more if I'm trying something like
Brett trying a new product obviously
I've been working with Demi for 6 years
so we're very close I don't really get
nervous nervous touching her yeah I mean
it's like you know it's like touching
family with your mouth like she's not my
mom my daughter yeah you know so yeah
you can I get comfortable and I think I
think I'm confident in Who I am and and
she and I have very similar styles which
makes it work so usually anything that I
create she's happy with yeah and if
she's not she'll tell me which is
awesome and I'm like all right start
over you're more nervous with you Levada
and you guys are hard to please I get
like tweets before please make her look
like this please do this please do this
so you know my number one I need to make
sure Debbie's happy so and then number
two I need to make sure you guys yeah
new favorite mascara oh I keep seeing
this everywhere okay they sent it to me
and I was like dream changer game
changer
it's Giorgio Armani and I think it's
yeah it's eyes to kill this is my other
little trick that I didn't do last time
if you really want to just load up
mascara I'm Glenn Close for me sometimes
I'll put like a tissue right here and
you just kind of pull back a little bit
and then really smash the lashes into
the front this is the brush and it just
really curls them but it also loads the
entire lash so then you're getting a
full coat of mascara and then it just
pulls them up too and that's without a
curler so we used three different
pencils underneath because when she
performs I can't have anything move yeah
so these are waterproof so I started
with a gold and I brought it all the way
from the inside and then I brought it
instead of bringing it right next to
lash line I kind of brought it lower
going to the outside so I like dipped
down this is like a shimmery Brown and I
started on the outer corner right next
to the lash line and brought it all the
way in to the very corner only I like
don't do dark all the way in but for
this I wanted it kind of smokier then I
brought a black and I did waterline but
just on the outside and then right along
the lash line so then you see that like
gradation of dark to gold so this is a
gold shadow and I'm just gonna go right
over that inner corner your eyes are
more green but her eyes are almost that
like a honey brown and so this kind of
like orange e copper color really makes
them more amber and now we're gonna
place them lashes so these are our
del-one 22s my other secret these are
kind of a sleeper lash people don't
really know about them but they're fan
tastic now we do now they're all gonna
be sold out I'm gonna go buy some so I
like to cut my lashes into pieces and
then apply them just in different chunks
[Music]
Demi's lashes are always insane so
everybody take note on what she's
telling you about these lashes and you
didn't even change the I look from
carpet to when she was performing no we
only had about 15 minutes between carpet
and performance and she had to warm up
so literally I just went in then I was
like we change your makeup nope perfect
so she changed her outfit made sure
everything was good a little touch-up
and then she went on and she looked
amazing like it's so crazy because she
was saying earlier off-camera that the
paparazzi shots make her makeup look a
little lighter with all the flashes so
many flashes when you're walking the red
carpet it's just constant so think about
all the light what happens when you put
so much light on your face it takes away
makeup so you have to you have to be
aware of that and do the makeup so that
it still looks like she's wearing
something but they don't not be too much
yeah on the stage she just looked like I
guess the lighting here and her longer
yeah but then again yeah the the
lighting was darker onstage they had one
little spotlight but it kind of followed
around it wasn't that much but then you
have the HD cameras yeah so HD cameras
and flash photography totally different
makeup yes but last but not least
everybody wanted to know what the lip
color was so I told you I would tell you
my tried and true love you Kylie so this
is the Kylie candy kay oh and I used the
liner and the and the lip and what I
love about this on Demi is just a
beautiful matte natural kind of like ma
vie rose I've never seen her work color
like I feel like I don't know yeah I
mean this because Matt we used to wear
it a lot last year and then I stopped
for a long time I'm so brought it back
out again for performance it's really
nice because I know it's not going to
move but it's just like a really great
fall color
so the key to this lip is that halfway
through the day if you need to reapply
just take off the center and then redo
it
that's so just take a makeup wipe a lot
of people will try to layer it you can
layer it probably once and then after
that don't layer it anymore because it
is matte and it's long wearing and thick
and that goes for any long wearing
lipsticks okay you just got engaged this
might be your wedding color I'm telling
you it's so there you have it oh there's
our AMAs look
[Music]